Let me go to class from Edmonton,
Kaas from Edmonton. What's going on?
Hey, David, can you hear me?
You're coming through loud and clear.
Perfect. Awesome. I'm from Britain. As you
know, I've actually been watching the show
for almost 10 years now. Wow. That's long,
Isaac. Doing it somehow. You were watching
the show before you got here is like in high
school. And I know, like, it feels like a decade.
Awesome. But it feels like 40 years to me.
So but I actually inspired me to
take political science in school,
which I'm doing right now at hand.
And what we're learning about and
something I thought was interesting
in Joe Biden's town hall is about kind of the
decline of the United States as a head Germany
and the rise of China and more specifically,
the United States loss of soft power.
And I was really interested
in what Joe Biden had to say
to the Republican when talking about foreign
policy. And I thought he kind of touched on this
previously. This is kind of a right wing talking
point or, you know, even chumps like anti China.
How do you think that the Democrats moving
forward to address the unit like the
United States, soft power issues and kind of
strengthening themselves on the world stage?
So there's really specific analysis that
could be done there that relates to, you know,
as micro as looking at where manufacturing
and energy industries are moving globally
like that. It would they would almost be like
industry analysis. But I think that we have
fallen so out of favor globally under Donald
Trump that there's a much broader analysis that
first has to be done, which is if you look
at the three global superpowers right now,
U.S., China, Russia, you look at the role of India
as a growing economy. You look at Nigeria as an
example, you know, and you start to go sort
of go down the list. The first step to even
be back in the picture is we need just some basic
things to happen. A president who doesn't think
climate change is a hoax created by the Chinese.
We're no longer even part of so many of the global
conversations about climate because of Trump's
position on climate that if that doesn't get
fixed, we're screwed. Right. Number two, ah
ah. Traditional Western Democratic allies,
U.K., Germany, France, Canada. You know
these places where the relationships have
soured because of how Donald Trump relates to
other people. If that stuff doesn't get dealt
with first, which I really am moderate, moderately
confident that a Biden administration would do
on policy, we may disagree with them on some of
the geopolitics, but at least they would rehab
our image and those relationships. That has to be
step one before we can even have a more serious
conversation about what's going to happen
with China and Russia in the next 20 years.
One hundred percent, I agree. I think it's
interstate and that Joe Biden mentioned it.
Hopefully he can address it
because I think a lot of people
in the last kind of shy away from it. I agree.
Ivan Watson, thank you. Cast from Edmonton. Thank
you so much for the. Thank you so much for the
call. Hope to hear from you again in the future.